S
ACTUALLY AN EMPLOYEE.
NONETHELESS, THIS GUY, SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED, THE SECOND
BIGGEST DONOR TO THE DEMOCRATS,
BEHIND ONLY GEORGE SOROS.
SO, THE QUESTION IS ANY TIME
SOMEBODY WHO IS A BIG DONOR GETS
IN BIG TROUBLE PEOPLE ON CAPITOL
HILL AND ADMINISTRATIONS GIVE
THE MONEY BACK.
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE WAS ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT THE MONEY SHOULD
GO BACK, YOU KNOW, DONATED TO A
CHARITY OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
SHE SIMPLY WOULD NOT ANSWER THE
QUESTION YESTERDAY.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO, LOOK, I'M COVERED BY THE
HATCH ACT.
LIMITED ON WHAT I CAN SAY AND
ANYTHING CONNECTED TO POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM HERE, I -- I
WOULD HAVE TO REFER YOU TO THE
DNC.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S OPINION
THOUGH DOES HE WANT THOSE PEOPLE
--
>> -- YOU ASKED ME TWO
QUESTIONS.
YOU ASKED ME WILL HE RETURN THE
DONATIONS AND THEN YOU ASKED ME
ABOUT HIS OPINION.
I'M ANSWERING THE FIRST PARTED
WHICH I'M COVERED BY THE HATCH
ACT FROM HERE.
I'M LIMITED ON WHAT I CAN SAY.
AND I JUST CAN'T TALK TO
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS OR
ANYTHING RELATED TO THAT I
CANNOT SPEAK ABOUT IT FROM HERE.
I AM FULLY COVERED BY THE HATCH
ACT WHICH I'M HAPPY TO SAY OVER
AND OVER AGAIN BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW HERE.
>> Brian: DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
GOT MONEY FROM HIM AT LEAST SIX
G.O.P. THAT WE KNOW OF.
AND WE'LL SAY, THIS HE WAS
MOSTLY CAMPAIGNS REACHED HIS
LIMIT THROUGH OTHER PEOPLE, HE
WAS VIOLATING CAMPAIGN FINANCE
LAWS FOR THE BENEFIT OF
DEMOCRATS AND AOC IS AMONG THE
LAWMAKERS THAT SAID YEAH, I
THINK THEY SHOULD GIVE THE MONEY
BACK.
>> Steve: HERE'S THE THING.
THE MONEY HE GAVE TO THE
DEMOCRATS IS MONEY HE STOLE FROM
THE CUSTOMER SO THAT MONEY WENT
RIGHT INTO THEIR POCKET.
SHE KEPT SAYING THE HATCH ACT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT CAMPAIGNS
THAT HAVE ALREADY HAPPENED.
THE HATCH ACT, WHEN YOU READ IT,
THERE IS A LOT OF GRAY THERE.
BUT SHE IS STICKING TO THE I'M
GOING TO SAY I CAN'T SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY COULD SAY SOMETHING.
BUT THEY CHOOSE NOT TO BECAUSE
IT IS EMBARRASSING.
AS I MENTIONED, CONGRESSMAN BILL
HUIZENGA WAS WITH US.
WE SAW HIM SOME OF THE B ROLL
CAPITOL HILL YESTERDAY.
HERE IS SOME OF THE OBSERVATION
ABOUT WHERE THAT MONEY WENT AND
THAT GUY IS IN TROUBLE.
>> I THINK THEY WERE SMITTEN
WITH THIS IDEA OF HAVING A
POLITICALLY PROGRESSIVE, SMART
ENTREPRENEUR WHO WAS GOING TO
REIMAGINE CAPITALISM, ALL WHILE
MAKING THEM GOBS OF MONEY.
AND HOW HE WAS MAKING THEM GOBS
OF MONEY WAS OUTRIGHT FRAUD.
IT'S REALLY SAD THAT YOU HAD --
AND THESE ARE BY THE WAY, NOT
JUST MOM AND POP RETAIL
INVESTORS.
THESE ARE SUPPOSEDLY
SOPHISTICATED I OBJECT
CONSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS WHO
BASICALLY JUST GOT SUCKED INTO
IT.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION TO SAY WHY
WASN'T HE ARRESTED A WEEK AGO OR
WHY COULDN'T THEY WAIT UNTIL
AFTER?
BECAUSE I THINK WE WOULD HAVE
FOUND OUT VALUABLE INFORMATION
HAVING HIM UNDER OATH, SWORN
UNDER OATH IN FRONT OF OUR
COMMITTEE ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN BEING USED
FOR HIS PROSECUTION.
>> Brian: SO WHY WOULD THAT?
ARE THEY EMBARRASSED BY SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT SAM WAS GOING TO
SAY ABOUT WHO HE GAVE TO?
BAHAMAS WANTS 256 WILL MILLION
DOLLARS BACK PURCHASED BY SAM
CRYPTO CONCERN AT THIS
EXCHANGES.
THEY FILED CHAPTER 11.
ALL THE INVESTORS WANT THEIR
MONEY BACK.
WE WANT OUR MONEY BACK AND
PROPERTY BACK.
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERNATIONAL FIGHT.
TOM BRADY, SHAQUILLE O'NEAL.
WHO ELSE?
GISELE?
WE HAVE, ALSO, KEVIN O'LEARY WHO
GOT $50 MILLION TO ENDORSE HIS
PRODUCT.
DO THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
COME FORWARD AND TRY TO GET THIS
MONEY BACK OR GIVE THE MONEY
BACK THAT THINK WERE PAID BY
THIS GUY?
>> Ainsley: THAT'S THE CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT THEY ARE SUING
THESE CELEBRITIES BECAUSE THEY
ENDORSED CRYPTO.
>> Brian: AND GOT PAID BY THIS
GUY.
>> Steve: HERE'S THE THING
ULTIMATELY PEOPLE PUT MONEY THEY
WORKED HARD TO GET INTO THIS
COMPANY.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT NOBODY
SEEMED TO KNOW HOW TO RUN A
COMPANY.
PEOPLE WHO PUT THE MONEY INTO
THIS CRYPTO COMPANY, YOU KNOW,
YOU GOT TO DO YOUR DUE
DILIGENCE.
ULTIMATELY, A LOT OF PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, IT WAS THE FEAR OF MISSING
OUT.
THESE CRYPTO CURRENCIES ARE
GOING UP AND PEOPLE DIDN'T WANT
TO MISS WHERE IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE IN VALUE SO MUCH THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO MISS IT, AND THEY
TURNED A BLIND EYE TO THE
TERRIBLE BUSINESS PRACTICES.
>> Ainsley: BERNIE MADOFF,
PEOPLE AND WE ALL KNOW PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK THAT USED HIM.
THEY GAVE EVERYTHING TO HIM
BECAUSE THEY TRUSTED HIM.
THEIR GRANDPARENTS TOLD THEM TO
TRUST HIM.
THEIR PARENTS.
THEY GAVE HIM EVERYTHING.
CRYPTO, BECAUSE PEOPLE KNOW IT
COULD GO UP AND DOWN AND AREN'T
REALLY SURE OF THE FUTURE OF
THAT.
HAVE WE HEARD OF ANYONE WHO LOST
EVERYTHING WITH HIM?
>> Brian: I KNOW SOME PEOPLE WHO
LOST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THEY SAY A MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
LOST BILLIONS -- HAVE LOST
BILLIONS.
SO THERE HAS GOT TO BE PEOPLE,
SMALL INVESTORS AND BIG
INVESTORS THAT LOST MONEY.
>> Steve: YEAH.
MORE QUESTIO